bon qu'est ce qui mobilise les français
en ce moment basse et sotchi ouais bah
oui bah du pain et des jeux de la tradi
et du ski alors j'ai fait l'effort j'ai
regardé quelques épreuves des jeux alors
y'a un truc sur lequel on ment pas c'est
vraiment des épreuves
des dents mais déjà regardé un truc
comme le combiné ski de fond le seul
homme c'est pas facile mais en plus se
taper l'interview du vainqueur après f
je suis super content c'est le plus beau
jour de ma vie c'est trop une belle
aventure as tu attends donc à une belle
aventure c'est de réussir à trouver un
stage rémunéré sais c'est une aventure
[Applaudissements]
pas forcément les journalistes sportifs
qui surenchérissent pour les jeux
olympiques c'est quand même ce grand
moment où tu aimerais savoir ce qui se
passe dans la tête d'un journaliste
sportif
quand tu n'es pas assez doué pour
l'action bon tu fais journalistes quand
et pas assez doué pour faire journaliste
eut fait journaliste sportif
non mais ça va vous avez évité de peu
mais
chose plus cyrus vous l'avez appris
ukraine 1
après le printemps arabe l'hiver slave
attention attention en ukraine le
mouvement des frères orthodoxes peut
arriver au pouvoir non je déconne en
europe
non mais bon sérieusement qu'est ce qui
se passe parce que ça mérite une analyse
géopolitique dans le vrai problème de
l'ukraine ce sont ses voisins ce que je
veux dire ça jamais été simple entre les
syldave et les bordures
et puis entre nous on s'en fout parce
qu'à part les bogdanov qui a une maison
de vacances dans les faubourgs
tchernobyl
moi en tout cas je c'est vrai c'est une
tragédie mais je comprends moi je
comprends que ce conflit déchaîne pas
plus les passions on peut pas
s'identifier pas ce sont des gens
extrêmement suspect ils veulent rentrer
dans l'europe
mais là il ya des morts et c'est vrai
que c'est pas tout y'a pire l'opposition
souffre de quelque chose de beaucoup
plus grave
elle a reçu le soutien de bhl
avait quand bhl s'en mêle t on dirait un
film de blake edwards c'est bhl c'est
l'inspecteur clouseau des relations
internationales
sauf que clouzot en foutant le bordel il
arrivait quand même à faire dégager le
méchant c'est un peu la seule ah bon
c'est la partie triste amour parce qu'il
faut aussi être un peureux n'est ce pas
giroud le footballeur qui s'est fait
choper avec une escort girl enfin est-ce
qu'on peut parler de tromperie à une
escort girl est un footballeur c'est pas
de la fidélité c'est du baby sitting
et le mec qui se sent obligé de
s'excuser ah je demande pardon en mon
équipe ma famille mon entraîneur mes
coéquipiers les supporters d'arsenal
dans mes oliviers quand tu te trompes ta
femme tu vas pas d'excusés auprès de ton
pote sauf si c'est la sienne
[Rires]
car ajoute une couche sur twitter je
dois me battre pour ma famille mon club
rien d'autre ne compte désormais arrête
olivier tu as tiré un coup et si tu fais
des excuses comme si tu étais
responsable la victoire de hollande aux
présidentielles n'ose pas grave
[Applaudissements]
je vais te dire olivier regarde moi dans
les yeux oui il faut que tu arrêtes de
croire qu'une femme va quitter parce que
tu la trompe olive si elle thème elle
peut même gérer les réserves et de
l'hôtel pour tes prochains 5 à 7 enfin
si elle tait mais il faut ton bonheur
réfléchis tu crois pas que c'est plutôt
elle de s'excuser de sa possessivité
maladive
tué maltraités olivier mais tu ne t'en
rends pas compte elle devrait être super
rassurer de vrai dire il me trompe avec
une femme ouf
voilà c'est un mec fasse un mec c'est
pas un mec pour tous quoi
en revanche les scores un peu con ouais
bah vraiment elle a une drôle de manière
de vouloir se faire un réseau et non
bonjour tu veux coucher avec moi c'est
possible c'est pas très cher mais en
revanche je me rattrape sur les produits
dérivés photo souvenir car postal vidéo
[Applaudissements]
moi un mec comme ça il me change des
autres sportifs là franchement c'est que
le type là qu'ils ont là par l'élu c'est
la vilenie qui était un nouveau record
soit la perche fausse excuse sport de
blaireaux quoi enfin franchement non
mais on en a soupé toute la semaine le
mec il a sauté seemed 16 alors la
question du journaliste peut-il aller
plus haut et lui tout fier ouais je peux
encore gagner 4 cm
pauvre homme quoi pauvrement au petit
pied en soirée il raconte quoi au gentil
alors toi c'est quoi ton talent bah tu
vois l'immeuble a tu me donnes une paire
j'arrive à atterrir dans le salon du
deuxième étage
économie montebourg strikes back alors
si un petit le chuck norris fait de
l'économie l'homme qui peut rallumer les
fous de florange avec une cigarette
électronique
alors l'état vient de racheter une part
dans peugeot alors il est super content
il a déclaré je suis fier d'annoncer aux
contribuables que désormais ils sont
aussi propriétaires de peugeot
arnaud moi j'en ai pas envie en fait
tu m'aurais dit ferrari apple peut-être
là
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
c'est bon depuis qu'elle a vu que ça
fait péter le décolleté ça passera
politique alors on a un nouveau premier
ministre vous n'avez même pas révélé
c'est pierre gattaz donc qui porte un
pin's un million d'emplois bon vu le
temps qu'a duré la folie du pis tu
comprends que dans la tête du mec
l'emploi c'est un truc des modernes
et c'est vrai qu'en ce moment on vit une
situation assez inédite un jean marc
ayrault il me fait de la peine il me
fait de l'argent marc ayrault tu sais
c'est l'homme qui est licencié depuis un
an mais personne ne lui a dit encore
au vieux tu es bien au bureau on dit
mais sinon tout va
3e âge alors on a finalement levé
l'immunité de dassault mec qui a racheté
ses voix pour se faire élire moi je vois
pas ce qu'il ya de choquant là dedans
aujourd'hui acheter des voix c'est
peut-être le seul moyen de faire
vraiment monter pouvoir d'achat des
électeurs
là on parle de supprimer le régime des
intermittents d'ailleurs je dois dire à
ce qu'elle aime beaucoup de gens qui
nous fîmes des intermittents moi je
soutiens ce régime c'est très important
pour nous autres les précaires
non moi ça me permet quand même de payer
une partie des impôts avec sa
nouvelle alors selon le fmi les grecs
sont en train de sortir de la crise
c'est vrai alors avec 28% de chômage
donc logiquement on est en plein boom
économique le
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater levine
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus